coming program on c-span 2's book tv
as many as 150 000 soldiers sailors and
airmen of partial jewish descent
served in adolf hitler's forces
historian brian mark rigg considers
their role
in the new book hitler's jewish soldiers
this talk is an hour and fifteen minutes
well for those of you i said i want to
thank
the university press of kansas and also
c-span's book tv for being here tonight
because this is a special event not only
have i had the honor of having
professor riggs speak here once but he's
here twice he was here about this time
last year
and brian received his bachelor's degree
with honors in history from yale
university in 1996.
he was then awarded the henry fellowship
for graduate study at cambridge
university
where he received his master's and his
phd
currently he is professor of history in
american military at american military
at american military university and he
has served as a volunteer in the israeli
army
and as an officer in the united states
marine corps in addition to his
extensive research travel
he has also engaged in humanitarian work
in romania bulgaria
the bahamas south africa and france
an unprecedented and invaluable result
of his work
and his efforts to record the stories of
these men in this book
has and has been his success in
gathering over thirty thousand pages of
records
more than five hundred hours of
videotaped interviews and three thousand
photographs
that document the military experiences
of these men
in 1997 the federal german military
archives
purchased what is now called the brian
mark rigg collection
and these materials are now housed in
the bundesliga
and fry in fryeburg ladies and gentlemen
would you please welcome
dr brian mark rigg
good evening ladies and gentlemen if i
don't use the microphone here at the
podium can everybody hear me
i always feel like i need to be in a
church or a temple if i'm behind
behind a podium i like to uh first
give some thanks to some very special
people who have helped me
throughout the years at yale university
i'd like to thank
professor paula hyman henry turner and
jeffrey sammons for their continued
support and help especially during my
undergraduate years and then i also like
to especially thank
my graduate professor at cambridge
university jonathan steinberg
who helped me tremendously during my
master's in graduate work
also i'd like to thank professor michael
barabao who helped me tremendously
in putting my work together and then
with some other projects that i've been
working on
he's been incredibly generous with his
time and helpful and he's a
research director at the showa
foundation for those who do not know
michael barabao and he's a brilliant a
brilliant historian
i also like to thank thank the william
colby symposium
for the award that they they gave me
this year for my
book for a first-time author in military
history
i was indeed honored by that before i
begin
talking to you tonight about my research
about jews and men of jewish descent who
served in the
german military during world war ii i'd
like to give you a little background on
my person which will
maybe help you understand a little bit
about my motivation and my
my drive to look into the subject matter
i was born in texas
in 1971 and was brought up in a very
protestant environment
i didn't know about my own jewish
background until i was 21
when i went over to germany started
researching my family's background
and found this out which was quite
shocking for me
and when i found this out i started
thinking to myself you know what would
have happened to me and my family had we
remained in germany
uh and not come over to america so this
played with my imagination quite a bit
at this time when i was 21
which was basically at the time when i
started really becoming very interested
in the holocaust in world war ii history
i also have the dubious honor of having
failed first grade twice
i have what people today call adhd or
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
and i also had a speech impediment when
i was young
i got my t's and f's mixed up uh quite
often so that made for quite interesting
conversation when i played with my
trucks
around my family's friends or are when i
asked the babysitter to tuck me into bed
and so on so my
my mother was very worried about me as a
young child
and after failing first grade for the
second time she realized she had to do
she had to do something very quickly to
get me back on track
so she looked around for special schools
and she found a wonderful school at
texas christian university called star
point and it was for severe learning
disabled kids
i met all the requirements and and was
accepted there
and when i went there if you look at my
file from the child study center there
in fort worth you will read that i had
the philosophy at the time i can't
i can't do it they would start doing a
test with me i would
finish halfway i mean i go halfway
through stop it i couldn't finish it
until the the doctor or the nurse that
was working with me i can't do it
so i went to the school i expressed my
frustrations i also expressed how
everybody thought i was abnormal or
that's at least the way i felt
i mean the church that we went to was
also the school that i had filled first
grade at twice so every time
we went to church on sunday the kids
that i had gone to school with didn't
let me forget my failure
now when i went to star point i had a
wonderful teacher her name was mary
stewart
and she pulled me underneath her wings
and she said no you're not a freak
you're not abnormal you're just
different and i'm here to help you find
your strengths
and in this one year i went from not
being able to pronounce individual words
to reading books at the third and fourth
grade level doing elementary geometry
and algebra
and in that year i realized i was a
contrarian in many respects somebody
told me i couldn't do something
well you know i'll look into it and see
what i can do also i learned
that the limitations put on people
usually come from themselves
not from what other people are saying
and so it's a matter of who you listen
to as far as criticism is concerned
and that teacher really instilled me a
great confidence and when i graduated
from yale university
mary stewart was there and i went on as
uh
sam anthony mentioned and thank you sam
for that warm introduction and
so i went on from yale and went on to
cambridge university where i did my
graduate studies
and i mentioned uh that story about my
background also to help you
understand a little bit about my
motivation also with this research when
i first began
doing this research i had a lot of
opposition from professors that i talked
to about it
and they said i wouldn't find anything
don't waste your time
and then here again that that voice
inside of me said well
i'll look into it they say i can't do it
i'll see what i can find out
now when people hear about my research
about jews and men of jewish descent who
served in the german armed forces during
world war ii
i often get the question how did you get
involved with this research
well it started in 1992 when i had
finished my first year at yale
university and decided to spend the
summer in germany
learning the language of my ancestors
and researching my family's background
i enrolled in the good institute for
german language and after a month of
studying there
i asked one of my instructors if he
could recommend a film i could watch to
improve my german
he in turn asked me well what subject
matters are you interested in
and i told him world war ii and
holocaust he then told me
you got to go see the film europa europa
so i went to a berlin theater in the
middle of the city bought my ticket
and entered an empty auditorium and
while waiting for the film to begin
i heard the doors open up behind me and
i turned to see an old man walk in
his eyes had not adjusted to the
darkness and he was a little
discombobulated with his surroundings he
leaned up against the wall and it was
evident that he was unsure of his
footing
so with my good texas upbringing i went
up to the man
and asked him if i could help him find a
seat he was very appreciative and i sat
him next to me
he quickly heard that my german was not
very good and he began to speak english
to me
and since he spoke fluent british
english he told me if i had any
questions during the film
that i should just ask we basically
translated the entire dialogue
and since we were the only ones there we
were not worried about bothering anyone
the film is about [ __ ] perel a german
jew who fled to poland in 1936
due to nazi persecution in 1939 when
germany invaded poland
he escaped to russia in 1941 when
germany invaded russia
he had nowhere else to run to and he was
taken prisoner outside of the city
immense
now during his interrogation he
emphatically denied that he was jewish
and he said that he was a folk deutsche
an ethnic german instead
his testimony was accepted and a few
days later he found himself serving in a
tank company
as their interpreter since he can speak
polish russian and german
he spends one year in this combat unit
and after this year
his company commander captain fun moon
chao who was childless at the time
decides to adopt him of all things and
sends him back to a hitler youth prep
school where he survived the war
now after this film i asked the
gentleman next to me his name was peter
millius
what he thought about this film and he
said wait it's very close to my own
history
would you like to go talk and i said
sure
and we walked down the street to a
restaurant where he would tell me a
story until the early hours
of the morning peter was of jewish
descent
and spent four years in the german armed
forces he told me about the fear he felt
of falsifying his documents
and serving in the german army and the
german military at the time was called a
veil mock i'll be using this term
quite often and he also told me about
the pain and suffering
experience when he lost his only brother
walter at the battle of leningrad in
1942
and he also told me about the constant
worries he felt for his half-jewish
mother
after the war the russians took him
prisoner and spent the next four and a
half years in a siberian prisoner war
camp
now after this experience with peter i
thought it was a strange coincidence
that here this kid from texas
goes to germany to learn the language of
his ancestors research his family's
background and the process goes to this
film
about a jew served in the nazi military
only to sit next to
a vermont veteran of jewish descent and
then one month later i go and research
my own family's background and i find
jews
in my family tree which i've never known
before so that's how i originally got
involved
involved with the subject matter now
what have i found
in the fall of 1992 i returned to yale
to begin my sophomore year and i began
to ask several of my professors about
looking for
more men of jewish descent who served in
the german military
and they all told me that they had
studied the holocaust in world war ii
history for 20 30
even 40 years and that they they had
never heard about this before
they recommended that i study some
serious german history instead of
chasing after some curious anomalies who
would not add anything to our
understanding of the third reich
and most of these professors were very
nice to me they gave me their
professional opinion
however once i found out that they had
not looked into the subject matter or
they didn't know anybody who had looked
into
it i decided to explore it i thought if
i could find 20 or 30 individuals like
[ __ ]
or peter that i could write an
interesting senior essay
so i began to conduct or take courses on
the holocaust and world war ii history
with great energy and by the end of this
year
i was awarded a scholarship from yale to
return to germany
live with peter and document his life
more thoroughly
after this summer with peter i came back
to yale
and i began to organize a seminar at
yale to bring [ __ ] perel
from israel to yale and speak there at
the
hillel and the history department which
actually happened in april
that year april 1994. i also during this
year began to conduct independent
studies about the world war ii and the
holocaust
and by the end of this year i had
documented seven
living valmock veterans of jewish
descent
now i wanted to go to europe to
interview these individuals so i applied
for several small scholarships
and got many of them i knew it was a
fight against time because of the age of
these veterans
so i actually decided to take off a year
between my junior and senior years
and dedicate the next 14 months to this
project
i mean to give you a sense of urgency i
i felt at the time
uh i'll tell you a quick story about
alexander stahlberg who i called up for
for an interview alexander shaw and also
i'll describe
uh how i went about doing my interviews
and scholburg is a perfect example for
that as well
i called him up when i went over to
germany and i said here stahlberg can i
please interview you and stallberg was
the adjutant to the famous field marshal
eric von manstein
who was actually born von lavinsky and
as a result many people thought he was
jewish and alexander stahlberg was of
jewish descent and he was claiming to me
that he had evidence that menstein was
also of jewish descent
so i called him up and i said here
stalberg this is the project i'm doing
can i come interview you and he says
sure i love to talk to you
however you better hurry up i have one
foot in the uh i want one foot in the
grave and another one on the banana pill
if you want to get here you better do it
now it's like okay here stallbrook i'll
get there as soon as i can
and so i packed up my backpack and this
is how i did my research i had a
backpack with a tripod
a radio a camera a computer a printer a
transformer
some extra food and some clothes there
and i would bike around german as soon
as i find somebody i set up my studio
interview them and basically rescue
their story before they took it to the
grave
so when i started looking at the map
where stalberg lived i was like oh my
goodness because i also had a mountain
bike and i go around germany
with a backpack on my back with a
mountain bike riding around
and i looked at the map and i saw he
lived in the middle of mecklenburg
at garto and the closest town there uh
with a train link was wittenberger
about 70 miles away i was like oh my
goodness you know how am i going to do
this
well you got to do what you got to do so
i got on the train really early one
morning
i got out of windenburger biked all day
uh 70 miles there
and got uh it was in december so it got
uh dark early
and i was on a dirt road and i didn't
see a few of the potholes so i
you know bloodied up my lip a few times
got very dirty so when i showed up at
his home i was a disaster
and he opened the door and instead of
you know inviting me in to give me some
teas like you probably want to take a
shower i was like yes please
so i cleaned up and then for the next
two days i conducted several interviews
with them
and they were a wealth of information
and sure enough
three weeks later he passed away not
because of the interview
but he was just an old guy in frail
health so this was the sense of urgency
i felt during this year i was a fight
against time
so this year my goals were to interview
between 20 and 30 individuals
make my german fluent and find
supporting documents in the german
archives
well in the first month alone i
conducted over 30 interview
30 interviews and it never slowed down
thereafter
by the end of this year i conducted
almost 200 interviews
and collected over 10 thousand pages of
documents i returned
to yale to begin my last year in the
fall of 1995
and i had the honor to write my senior
essay under the supervisions
uh supervision of professors jeffrey
sammons henry turner and paula hyman
i graduated with honors in history and
was awarded the henry fellowship
to conduct graduate studies at cambridge
university
and while at cambridge i had the honor
to study under jonathan steinberg
many of you will know who his famous
father a famous rabbi in new york was
and that was milton steinberg who wrote
the book as a driven leaf
now when i was in cambridge i spent on
average
two weeks out of every every month going
to austria or germany
to conduct more interviews and collect
more documents by the end of this year i
conducted almost 400 interviews and
collected over 20 000 pages of documents
the federal archives became interested
in my research inspected my documents
and then offered me an archive office in
their
federal archives in freiburg in exchange
for my collection
i took them up on their offer moved to
germany and for the next two years
i organized my collection it is now
called the brian mark rigg collection
and it comprises over as sam uh
introduced
as he was introducing me he mentioned it
comprises over 30 000 pages of documents
over 500 hours of video with 430
interviewees
and over 3000 photographs it documents
by name and rank over 1700 men
who were of jewish descent and served in
the german armed forces during world war
ii
and many of these men 1700 and many of
these men were very prominent
individuals
during the third reich and world war ii
history
and during my speech when i describe
people or use terms like
half jew quarter jew or aryan please in
your minds i
have these terms in quotation marks they
are nazi terms
but they give the history its meaning
the first
prominent individual i like to describe
to you
is state secretary half jew earhart milk
milk became a powerful field marshal
during the third right phil marshall's
equivalent of a five-star
general he ran the luftwaffe the german
air force
and was his most powerful figure for
personnel planning production
and strategy his greatest contribution
to the luffaffa was to organize
the massive program of aerial rearmament
began in 1933
and by 1936 under milk's leadership the
german air industry had become a first
class organization
producing modern aircraft reaching the
faffa flying units
hitler had said in 1936 that there are
two names
linked with the birth of our luflofa
gurings
and milks in april of 1940
when germany started to encounter a lot
of problems with his invasion of norway
milk skills as an excellent organizer
and administrator helped lay the
foundation for air power
in norway hitler was eventually
successful in this norwegian campaign
thanks to the solid leadership
generals like milk displayed now had
germany been unable to secure its
northwest flank in norway in 1940.
hitler probably would have been
unwilling and possibly unable
to launch his invasion of france one
month later
and for his accomplishments during the
norwegian campaign hitler awarded milk
the knights cross the richter croits
the u.s equivalent of the medal of honor
right here always worn around the neck
a few months later after the successful
conclusion of the war in france
milk was one of three luftwaffe generals
who hitler promoted to field marshall
and by 1944 this half
jew ranks seventh among hitler's
subordinates
now many of you might be asking yourself
how in the heck does a half jew become
a field marshal in the luftwaffe back
then well hitler in his warped ideology
felt like he could look at somebody if
they looked like an aryan phenotypically
they had blonde hair
blue eyes a good military track record
he would actually give them the kosher
stamp of approval ovarian hood
milk received one of these exemptions or
one of these
awards if you will and also what makes
milk's case
quite interesting is what his mother did
and she's an example of what many
mothers tried to do
most were unsuccessful she was
successful and that is
she went to goring and said you know my
jewish husband
anton milk is not the father of my six
children
but it's my aryan lover who happens also
to be my
uncle they inspected the documents they
looked at the files and sure enough they
declared all six children
aryan so during the third reich jewish
ancestry was
horrible but incest was all right
the next distinguished general i'd like
to tell you about is half jew helmut
villberg
villberg was an incredibly intelligent
man and a first-rate commander who
helped develop the operational concept
that we today call blitz creek
during world war one he was the first
air commander to organize and employ
whole air groups in the ground
support role he was one of the most
senior air commanders in the german air
force and commanded over 700 planes
during the flanders campaign in 1917
during a high point of german air power
during the great war
the army considered him a leading
pioneer in ground support tactics
and in 1920 after the versailles treaty
was in full force in germany
he was hand-picked by the government and
military leadership to be the
luffaffa uh chief or commander
that was operating secretly in russia in
1935
when the luftwaffe officially came back
into being so to speak because it was
called different a different term in
world war one
he prepared the manual which served as
the lufafa's primary expression of
battle doctrine
into world war ii also in 1935
he was head of the the war college 1936
hitler allowed him to be the staff
officer of the condor legion during the
spanish civil war
he was in charge of the entire operation
now this
civil war uh provided germany with more
combat trained veterans than any other
military in the world when hitler
launched the globe
into world war ii in 1939
one general wrote of vilberg after the
war that owing to his career and
abilities
he was the logical choice to command the
luff off of a position
given to guring because of party
politics he was tall
good looking and a pleasure to work for
unfortunately
he was a 50 percent jew he would die in
a plane crash in 1941.
the last distinguished commander i'd
like to tell you about is quarter jew
admiral bernhardt roga roga
was the most successful surface raider
our auxiliary cruiser captain during
world war
ii these ships were also called q-ships
now what surface raiders were is that
they would
these ships would masquerade around the
high seas as freighters or merchant
marine vessels and when they would get
close to enemy ship
they would drop their hidden doors
revealing their cannons until the enemy
either surrender or we're going to blow
you out of the water
roga captured or sank almost two dozen
enemy warships for a combined total
150 000 metric tons he was awarded the
oak leaves
to his knight's cross for his
accomplishments during world war
ii basically he was awarded two medals
of honor
also he probably had a profound impact
on the way japan launched his invasion
of southeast asia in 1941
after it attacked us at pearl harbor in
1940
roga captured a british steam ship which
had several confidential documents on
board
drawn up by the british war cabinet
among many other things
these documents had detailed notes on
british war strength
in east asia had an assessment on the
feasibility of australia and new zealand
coming into war if japan were were to
attack and then how they would
operate under under the commonwealth
it also had detailed a blueprints on
singapore's fortifications
and then had an assessment on the
feasibility of japan entering the war
roga turned these invaluable documents
over to the japanese and the japanese
emperor
awarded him a samurai sword now only two
other germans during world war ii were
awarded summarized swords by the emperor
of japan
and they were rike's marshall guring and
field marshall rommel
and with the success that japan had with
its invasion of southeast asia in late
1941
and early 1942 one can see that they put
to good use
the documents roka gave them so as one
has just heard
many of these men who i have documented
were not curious anomalies
but they played very significant roles
during the history
of world war ii and the third reich
now recently interest in world war ii in
the holocaust has grown dramatically
books on the subject matter frequently
hit the bestseller list and newspapers
run articles on the holocaust or world
war ii history
every week whether it is a doctoral
thesis calling the vast majority of
germans hitler's willing executioners
or an expose on ibm's role in the
holocaust it seems like the general
public just cannot get enough
and also with spielberg's brilliant
films schindler's list
and saving private ryan the thirst for
knowledge about
world war ii and the holocaust has grown
even more
now it is true however that there are
many areas of study relating to
the holocaust and world war ii history
that remain largely unexamined
and poorly understood and my research
represents
one of these areas of study and while i
do not pretend to offer the final
word i do hope to provide my readers and
listeners
with a new way of looking at one of the
most central issues
of the history of the holocaust and the
third reich namely
jewish identity to understand my
research one must first be aware
of jewish law halacha and how it defines
a jew because this causes a lot of
confusion about my research
for jews today especially observant jews
a jew is a person who is born of a
jewish mother or who converts to judaism
knowing this will help one understand
the confusion surrounding the men i have
documented
and whether they are jewish or not also
to understand my research
one must have a fundamental
understanding of the nazi racial
laws in 1935 the nazis issued the
nuremberg laws which created the racial
categories
of jew half jew and quarter jew
a full jew according to the nazi racial
laws was a person who had three or more
jewish grandparents
or a person who practiced the jewish
religion
a half jew also called a michelin
of the first degree michelin singular
michelin a plural
these are horrible terms uh michelin
means bastard hybrid
mutt just shows you what the nazis
thought of these people
and a half jew and it's a very strange
concept one man told me who i
interviewed he's like you know
being half jewish it doesn't exist it's
like being half protestant or half
circumcised
but we had to take it we had to take it
seriously he told me
now i have to according to the nazi
racial laws was a person who had
two jewish grandparents and a quarter
jew or a michelin of the second degree
had one jewish grandparent now for all
the
nazi talk of the jews being a race
they ultimately had to use religious
criteria to define that race
death certificates birth certificates
marriage certificates throughout germany
always noted a person's religion
involved and as a result the nazis had
to use these documents to define
somebody's race
instead of looking at their blood to use
their nazi term
are there physical characteristics of
having big noses big ears
and flat feet knowing this
one sees just how bankrupt the nazi
racial laws were
nonetheless people had to take them very
seriously and they caused
a tremendous amount of trauma and pain
and tens of thousands of families
and by way of illustration to show a
little bit of the confusion that went on
the next dooring is quite next story is
quite telling in 1937
five-year-old half jew erwin fuchs
boarded a crowded streetcar with his
older
brother now they have both been told by
their parents they could not sit down in
public transportation because the nazis
in their town had prohibited this
of people who were of jewish descent so
they remained standing and as the tram
was moving down
the street an elderly woman scooted
across her seat
and said to irwin here's half a seat for
you little one
irwin became confused he looked down at
the old woman and then
up at his brother and asked which side
of me is jewish
the left or right now this sad story
dramatically illustrates the pain and
confusion and trauma that swept
literally hundreds of thousands of
people's
lives and turned their whole identity
upside down
now when people hear about these nazi
racial laws i often get the question
how could people affected by these laws
serve in the military
i thought anybody with any jewish
descent was exterminated
well this is where my research becomes
very interesting
full jews who i have documented who
served in the german armed forces during
world war
ii did so with false documents as far as
their commanders were concerned they
were aryans
and treated accordingly in other words
the official policy of the nazi
government was that full jews could not
serve
half jews on the other hand had to serve
the conscription laws of 1935 included
half
jews in the draft however they could not
become ncos
or officers without hitler's personal
permission in other words they couldn't
become professional soldiers
now the one hand hitler possibly allowed
these men to serve because he did not
want to deny the vamok
so many potential soldiers uh from his
experience in world war one
he knew how many men could be lost in
one battle and perhaps he felt he needed
to fill
every person he possibly could without
bending his ideology
too much once the war came on the other
hand
it is very difficult to find rational
explanations for hitler's behavior
allowing tens of thousands of half-jews
to serve in the military
did not make sense when looked at the
glass of nazi racial ideology
and hitler and the nazis would soon
encounter a lot of problems with this
policy
after the successful conclusion of the
war in poland in 1939
tens of thousands of half-jews returned
home only to find that their families
were being even more persecuted
than before they left for war dad had
lost his job
mom was being slapped around the street
by gestapo agents
grandma was being arrested by the ss and
thrown in prison
and many of these soldiers went to their
commanders and said hey look
i served this country honorably i have
the iron cross
i've bled for this nation look how
you're treating my family this is a
disgrace
and to the credit of thousands of aryan
officers they send such complaints
of the chain of command even the
families affected by this persecution
felt the need to get into the action and
write the government and military
directly
for example a very brave courageous
woman full jew
clara von mettenheim wrote commander in
chief of the army in 1949 general von
brauchich
on behalf of all half-jewish soldiers
for him to work with the party
to alleviate problems families like hers
families like hers experience
she wrote i speak to him as a mother of
three soldiers and as an old army
officer's wife
my sons are soldiers from head to toe
the crown prince of germany is the
godfather of one of my sons and general
fonsect
held the other one at his christening my
sons are half jews because of me and
while they were serving on the front
lines in poland
we were persecuted on the home front as
if there were no more important tasks to
be done during the war
please stop this mistreatment of half
jewish soldiers and that of their
families
now clara von mettenheim felt desperate
and she did not understand why a family
of her social standing should endure
such persecution
she pleaded with bralkich to remove the
obstacles her sons faced
and she also obviously felt deeply
responsible for the misfortune that had
visited them
she also described how disturbed they
had made one of her sons deter
phil when he returned home from the
front only to find that his mother had
been slapped
and and hit basically down to the ground
by an ss officer
and that his sister had been expelled
from several organizations
one of them being her school he also had
accompanied her to the jewish affairs
office
in frankfurt to get her jewish
identification papers on hermes vague
and on that day he wore his full dress
military uniform
not to provoke anyone but because he had
to return to his unit
later that evening well when they
entered this office
the nazi bureaucrats there were
horrified to see this jewish woman
with her soldier's son and she received
her id papers under humiliating
circumstances
detroit later returned to his unit that
evening very disturbed reported this to
his commander
who then sent the complaint at the chain
of command and clairefon mettenheim
obviously felt the need to write the
commander
and chief of the army about this story
now when this story reached hitler
he declared and many stories like this
actually did reach hitler but when he
heard about this story with claire from
manheim and dieter amongst others
he declared such events intolerable he
said that either they needed to protect
the jewish parents of half jewish
soldiers
or they needed to discharge the half
jews well hitler said
we cannot protect full jews discharge
the half jews
and this discharge order went out on the
8th of april 1940.
now all half jews serving in units that
would invade denmark and norway on the
9th of april
remained untouched because this
discharge order never reached them
and the vast majority of the men who
were serving in units that would invade
france one month later
also remained untouched due to
bureaucratic mishaps
and the secrecy involved with the
invasion however
after hitler successfully defeated
france in only six weeks
many of these men were found and
dismissed according to one man who
worked in the supreme headquarters of
the army who i've been able to interview
he said by the end of nineteen forty
over seven uh seventy thousand half
jews have been dismissed now from my
research
fifty percent of all the half jews who i
have documented
were still serving by the summer of 1941
and this indicates to me that many of
these half jews
were not known to be half jews the
authorities many of these half jews were
successful
at hiding their ancestry and that this
discharge order wasn't being widely
enforced
also this discharge order hitler had
decreed
within this order that any half jew who
had performed well in battle
was allowed to apply for clemency and
when one did so this allowed him to
remain
several months in his unit as he got his
application together and as a decision
was given so that's the policy that
affected half
jews quarter jews also had to serve with
the conscription laws of 1935
but they like their half-jewish
counterparts cannot become ncos or
officers without hitler's
personal permission and this policy did
not change throughout the entire war
now when people hear about half jews and
quarter jews serving i often get the
question
well how many people are we actually
talking about here
well looking at assimilation records
birth rates mixed marriage rates
and talking to a few statisticians and
mathematicians
i conservatively estimate that sixty
thousand half jews
and ninety thousand quarter jews served
in the valmocs
during world war two now when one knows
that seventeen and a half million men
went through the ranks of the vamox one
sees that this number is
a very small percentage i mean less than
one percent
of these 150 000 michelin soldiers
represent the total size
of the german armed forces back then but
in light of the holocaust
this number is quite shocking and this
number is both shocking
and important for what it tells us about
how jewish identity was viewed
constructed and contested by german
citizens
nazi leaders military commanders in the
german jewish population within german
borders
and for what it tells us about how these
perceptions save some
while condemning others to the death
camps also my research is very important
for what it tells us about hitler
and his involvement with the jewish
question especially giving exemptions to
michelina
generals admirals ubo captains
battleship captains
fighter aces and tens of thousands of
ordinary michelin soldiers
all served because hitler allowed them
to
many of them with a personal exemption
from him now it seems like there were
three types of exemptions that allowed
a half jew to remain in the military the
first type
uh simply allowed him to remain the
second type allowed him to remain
and be promoted these forms are called
gennami
are special permissions the third types
were called deutsche bluetech cleron
or the german blood declarations and
this allowed a recipient to describe
himself as an aryan
and all official documentation now how
many men actually receive some form of
clemency
well due to the chaotic filing system it
is very difficult to ascertain the exact
number
the different departments and offices
that dealt with these applications did
not create a central database
nonetheless after the war hitler
secretary of state lambert said that
hitler gave
thousands during his rule and i concur
with this assessment
especially when one knows that hitler
had decreed that any michelin soldier
who had been severely wounded in battle
i.e
lost both his legs his arms his eyesight
was to be recto
actively declared an aryan to the date
of his injury
also hitler had decreed that any
michelin soldier who had died in combat
was to be posthumously declared an aryan
hitler said and i quote
i do not want to be ungrateful to
michelin soldiers who have shed blood
for the third reich
before i go on to the next section very
quickly this is a
although this was this picture was not
used for an application
this is a typical application a
photograph
series that was a requirement hitler
laid great emphasis
on how somebody looked in the
application and if he looked
phenotypically jewish he was immediately
rejected
and if he looked aryan he uh he had good
chances of being
aryanized and he always wanted front
and side shots of the person and here's
an example of those type of photographs
now when people hear about tens of
thousands of michelin and serving and
that many of them were generals and
admirals
u-boat captains battleship captains
divisional commanders and so on i often
get the question
well didn't these men know about the
holocaust
soldiers in war usually have enough
trauma with the physical hardships and
the psychological burdens with killing
and death
that constitute the everyday life of
combat then also have to worry about
their persecution
and the persecution of their relatives
at the hands of their own countrymen
jewish and michelin soldiers not only
served in armed forces controlled by a
government hostile to them as
racially inferior beings but many of
them did so at a time when they were
experiencing their own persecution
witnessing the persecution of their
loved ones and even the occasional
deportation
and death of a family member so as i
conducted this research i
closely looked at the question did these
men know about the holocaust
and when i say the holocaust i mean the
systematic extermination of six million
jews under hitler
and when i began this research i thought
that overwhelmingly yes i would find
that all these men knew about the
holocaust
how could they not know shockingly
i found the opposite to be true yes many
of these men knew about
deportations but where their relatives
were being deported to
was beyond their knowledge many of them
knew about concentration camps
but what actually was going on in the
camps was beyond their imagination
many of them knew about executions going
on in the east but many of them
thought that these executions or many of
them rationalized
that these executions were for criminals
prisoners of war
partisans most of them did not know that
when their relatives were deported
they most often were deported straight
to their deaths
and on average each man who i've
documented lost seven between seven and
eight relatives in the holocaust
and the most telling fact to prove these
men's ignorance is the story of half
jews and organization
tote the ot forced labor camps
by late 1941 tens of thousands of half
jews had been dismissed
and here's an irony of history
while most of these men were dismissed
and one would think okay it's going to
be really bad for them
they were lucky because of their status
of being half
jews because they were also half aryans
so they were protected by that side to
some degree
and the nazis didn't really know what to
do with them yet so most of them
returned home
and they found work or they still began
to study most of the time it was
substandard work
and in the universities they were not
usually allowed to study what they
wanted to because
medicine and law for example were
unworthy uh
i mean they were unworthy to study these
you know prestigious topics
so they had to take lesser uh degrees
but nonetheless they were still able to
study
and they were relatively safe at home or
they were able to work
while their aryan comrades had the honor
to go to russia
and get slaughtered when one knows that
75
of all germans who died in world war ii
died on the russian front
one sees as a percentage wise that half
jews provided a higher percentage than
their aryan comrades
but by 1944 hitler had decided to
utilize this valuable pool of manpower
and he started to deport them to force
labor camps now had half jews known
about the holocaust why did they report
to their own deportation stations
the vast majority of the men who i have
documented reported when called
and this indicates to me that they did
not know because had they known one
would think they would have done
everything they could have to
gone into hiding obtained false
documents and gone underground or even
tried to escape to
switzerland or sweden now it is true
that it was very difficult to find a
hiding place in nazi germany back then
and obtaining false documents was a
risky business at best
also reaching switzerland was very
difficult because the border was heavily
patrolled on both sides
and also sweden was also very difficult
to reach being separated from germany by
the baltic sea
nonetheless had these men known about
the holocaust one would think that they
would have tried their luck no matter
what the cost
and many of them had a chance to make a
quick get away most of them received
their deportation notices from the
gestapo or local employment agencies
which gave them several days if not
months until they had a report
nonetheless most reported when called
and this was the beginning of their own
holocaust
as one man told me he said i didn't know
why we were being called up or where we
were going to
i didn't even know about auschwitz until
after the war and i simply
thought my life was not in danger here
was a man who lost seven relatives
in auschwitz another man told me he said
even when i was in the camp and talking
amongst the other half jews
none of us came to the idea that the
relatives that we had who were deported
before us
were deported to their deaths it was
simply beyond our imaginations
renowned professor in england ian
kershaw eloquently describes how
difficult it was to know about the
holocaust during world war ii
he wrote during the war years interest
in the jewish question
declined further the deportation passed
off apparently little heated
by the population the german people seem
to have asked
little and cared less about the fate of
the jews
the war its worries and deprivations
dominated public opinion
the jews were out of sight and out of
mind
knowledge of executions going on the
east were widespread
and rumors of executions going on
in the east circulated details about the
systematic gassing program
appear however to have been largely
unknown
now there are many historical insights
one can glean from my research
besides seeing just how difficult it was
to know about the holocaust
my research shows us that we cannot look
at the third reich and extremes of black
and white
not every german soldier who wore
uniform back then was a nazi
as we used that term today and not
everybody of jewish descent was a victim
of the death camps
also my research shows us that there
were hundreds of thousands of people
who were persecuted for being jewish not
because they themselves called
themselves jewish
but because the nazis called them jewish
and treated them accordingly
and what this is and with this in mind
is interesting to note that half jews in
poland and russia
were labeled as full jews and sent off
to the death camps
although many of them had converted to
christianity and assimilated and had no
more contact to judaism but since they
were half
slavic they didn't have that half aryan
germanic blood to protect them
and they didn't have those aryan
relatives to help them out
they were deemed unworthy and they were
slaughtered within that six million
so one sees with this history just how
complicated life was
during the third reich the michelin
policy the nazi shows was a maze of
confusion and contradiction which
uh reflected the regime's own
uncertainty with how to deal with
germans
a partial jewish descent now it seems
like there were many reasons why it was
so
difficult to implement this policy one
reason was that the nazi ideology of
race
came into conflict with maintaining
power had hitler been too aggressive
with his mistreatment
of michelin in the 1930s and 1940s he
might have lost the support
of thousands of aryans who held key
positions in the government
economy and military who had michelin
relatives nathan stoltzfus
historian brings this point out very
well in his book resistance of the heart
also until 1935 this category of people
the michelin never existed
so the bureaucrats had to rely on
denunciations honest confessions
and church and court and temple records
to identify these people
in the van mock discharge orders were
often hindered by
officers who valued a trained soldier
and an honest comrade
more than they did the nazi racial laws
i mean the very fact that hitler
reserved the right to give exemptions to
his racial laws
shows that even he saw how contradictory
and confusing they could be
but as renowned professor at yale
university henry turner wrote
hitler was driven by an unshakable
conviction that reality would eventually
conform to his will
hitler truly believed that he can make
his
irrational philosophy meet up with
reality and his diplomatic and military
triumphs from 1933 to 1940
reinforce his own belief in his
infallibility as leader
uh as the prophet leader and racial
hygienist
hitler perverted the german legal system
and he forced it to implement his racial
ideas as laws
now in light of how aggressively he
pursued the persecution of the jews it
is quite shocking how much time he spent
on the michelina
especially giving them exemptions i mean
maybe one can understand the
careful analysis of keeping a michelin
general
at his post but many to whom hitler gave
an exemption to
were privates common soldiers who had no
bearing on the war's outcome
i mean hitler giving these exemptions to
these type of men and the support of
thousands of aryan officers in
in in connection with these applications
contradicted the nazi world view i mean
the very fact that the arch
anti-semite himself adolf hitler gave
even one exemption
is quite shocking but he gave thousands
but as professor kirshal wrote
nothing was as it seemed during the
third reich i mean many of hitler's
actions seemed to demonstrate that he
believed
that jewish blood to use a nazi term
again even in minute amounts
ruined a person other actions seem to
demonstrate that he believed in mendel's
theories of genetics
and that a half jewish a michelin
soldier could actually inherit all of
his blood
from his aryan parent hitler continued
to waver on facts about race
and many of his decisions during the
third reich did not reflect the true
categories of race so central to nazi
rhetoric
and ideology also hitler's policy with
the michelina
shows the triumph of nazi ideology over
reason
in 1942 when hitler was encountering a
lot of difficulties at the ballot
a battle of stalingrad he could have
recalled probably around 70 000 half
jews who he had dismissed at that time
but instead he focused on a few hundred
men to see if they were blonde
uh enough blue-eyed enough to be
declared of german blood
i mean was did hitler have nothing
better to do
than at the height of the battle of
stalingrad than to look at an
application from a private
to see if he looked aryan enough to be
brought into the fold
i mean hitler shows just how obsessed he
was with the racial
ideology under the nazis with this uh
process and with these actions
he also demonstrates with this
behavior that he valued an aryan society
more than he did winning the war
as hitler has said the jewish question
takes priority over all other matters
now after the unsuccessful bomb attack
on his life in 1944
he actually started to revoke most of
the exemptions that he had given to date
now discharging so many high-ranking
officers many of them generals with the
knights cross
did not make strategic sense at this
time period but as the war worsened
hitler's persecution of not only of the
jews but of the michelin
dramatically escalated and had germany
prolong the war
god forbid had hitler won the war
half jews would have shared the fate of
the full jews
and quarter jews would have been
selectively sterilized and in some cases
as the degree was written
exterminated if they looked to jewish
and that was a sad fate that awaited
michelin soldiers
now as many of you probably have thought
about during this talk
my research often departs from history
and enters into the realm
of identity and before i tell you two
quick stories i'd like to give you the
background on this photograph here
in 1939 a memorandum went out from the
propaganda ministry
in berlin under goebbels that to several
german military units asking for the
most
aryan looking soldier you have
werner goldberg won the competition
and for three months he was the nazi
propaganda child for the typical aryan
german soldier
until they found out that his father was
jewish
here's just another example of how
absurd the nazi racial laws were
now the first story i'd like to tell you
about let's call the gentleman
heinrich byer that's not his real name
and uh buyer had served two years
in the uh a german military was
discharged sent to a forced labor camp
and after the war he said you know i'm
going to do something for my
ok luckily he survived he said i'm going
to do something for my my jewish family
i'm going to go to israel
i'm going to fight in the wars there and
i'm going to help establish that country
so he goes there for several years he
fights in the battles there and in 1953
his battalion commander calls him to the
duty hut and says you need to go down to
the courthouse and get your id papers in
order
so he goes down to the courthouse and as
the bureaucrat is looking through his
file he says okay
you're persecuted for 12 years for being
a jew in nazi germany
uh you served in the military how that
happened he explained
you were sent to a forced labor camp you
lost your father in auschwitz
uh what about your mother oh my mother
well she's a christian she's gentile
oh said the bureaucrat you're not jewish
wait a minute buyer said
for 12 years i was persecuted for being
a jew i served in a forced labor camp
my father died in auschwitz i now have
served this country as an officer i'm a
captain
for six years i've been wounded seven
times you're telling me i'm not jewish
i said hey i'm just telling you what's
on the books you can either prove that
your mother is jewish
or you can convert to judaism well i'm
an atheist buyer said well we have a
problem say the bureaucrat
buyer got so fed up with this process
that he went back to germany he said
maybe in that democratic country i can
decide who i want to be
the next story i'd like to tell you
about is about heinrich hamburger
hamburger i just finished up
interviewing him outside of munich and i
was packing up my bag putting all my
things
in it from my studio my wandering studio
and as i was doing so his girlfriend
walked in and said you know you should
take the young american tonight and he
tried to hush her up very quickly
she's like no hiney the young american
would find it very interesting you
should take him this evening
so i looked at her hamburger and i asked
him what's going on this evening
and he very sheepishly looked down at
the ground and he said uh
uh the veterans from my unit we we get
together at a bar
once a month and talk about our lives
and drinks drink some beer and
and talk about the war would you like to
come i was like yeah
that sounds very interesting he said
well well
if you come you got to promise me two
things the first thing is you can't tell
anybody that i'm a half jew for the last
60 years i've kept this hidden and i
like to keep it that way
i was like okay hamburger i won't tell
anybody that you're jewish
he's like and second of all you can't
tell them what you're studying because
then the one why you came and talked to
me
you got to tell them you're studying
something like um they are artillery
tactics of the mountain troops or
something of that sort
i was like well how about i tell them
i'm studying the social dynamics of the
van mock on the company level
and he said he went yeah yeah that's
good that's good tell him you're doing
that i was like
okay here hamburger that's what we'll
tell them what i'm studying so a few
hours later we entered this bar and as
we opened the door the smell of smoke
smarted our
nostrils and i could hear the men
singing world war ii songs i couldn't
believe i was there
and he took me to a back room a
conference room where there was about 40
veterans
and many of them had been told
beforehand because hamburger called up a
few of them to tell
them about the young american historian
so they're very eager to meet me and
they brought their diaries and some of
them brought their medals and
photographs
and as we walked into the room hair
hamburger i could tell he's very nervous
he's latched on to my right shoulder as
if to prevent me from jumping up on the
table and telling everybody that he was
a half jew
but after about an hour he realized i
was being very discreet and he left me
to my own devices and i started working
my way
around the table and i eventually came
in a conversation with a company
commander
who was still alive at the time 93 years
old big brood of a guy
about six foot four 220 pounds he had
scars all up and down his forearms and
hands where
in 1943 he had been knocked unconscious
by a concussion grenade
and when he came to he was in a russian
prisoner war camp and he was put on
burial
details and during one of these details
he noticed on some nearby hills where
the russian guards were watching them
that they were not doing their job very
well they weren't paying attention very
well
so he had his men bury him alive
in a wooden crate and when he was sure
the russian guards were gone he clawed
his way out of this crate out of the
earth and made it back to his lines
where he served two more years as an
infantry officer
so this guy was pretty hardcore who i
was talking to
and as he was describing the tactics he
used and how he trained his men
his experiences in russia i asked them
you know during my study about the
social dynamics of the van market on the
company level
i've come across an interesting
phenomenon about jews and men of jewish
descent who served in the nazi military
have you ever heard about this before he
looked at me in a very
surprised way he spotted hamburger in
the other end of the room and then said
to me in a conspiracy tone
don't tell hamburger but we know he's a
jew
i won't say anything
now this story is very important for
several things that it tells us
and the first thing that i told me back
then and it was something i was
continually encountering which i was not
expecting to find and that is that for
many of these men's comrades they had
accepted the so-called michelin
into the fold many of them had known
about the racial background many of them
actually tried to help these people
and their families in their precarious
situation and that was something i was
not expecting to find
another thing that was very interesting
about getting back to that very first
point also
this company commander who i was talking
to on three separate occasions he wrote
recommendations for hamburger to get him
the german blood declaration
because hamburger had been severely
wounded in battle
and under the clause of exemptions if
you were severely wounded in battle you
could apply for clemency and on three
occasions this company commander did so
and on the third occasion
he was finally successful hamburger to
this day still believes it was his
battalion commander who died in battle
not his company commander now the second
thing that was very interesting that
this story tells us
and this is something i found
consistently with the men i i
interviewed is that a lot of them cower
at being called jewish
and they do everything they can to
prevent this knowledge from getting out
there to the public
but what's interesting about hamburger
and he's also an example of many men who
i've documented
and that is is when you walk into his
office his bookshelf
is lined with books about judaism german
jewish history
and israel even a menorah in the corner
of his room
he's fascinated by this topic and when i
asked him about this he's like yeah yeah
i when i called him on this really he's
like yeah i know i'm a paradox
i'm a closet jew so as one sees when
looking at this research that i
especially have done identity was very
crucial to look at
and identity is very difficult to define
i mean where does it come from does it
come from my parents
does it come from the religion i'm born
into does it come from the government
i'm born under
can i decide who i am am i black or am i
white
am i a jew or am i a christian am i
worthy to live
or am i worthy not to live who decides
the answers to these questions
and i believe it is very important to
look at these questions because
ultimately
the way i come to define myself directly
influences the way i understand
and interpret uh history and more
importantly
the way i treat others and therein lies
the wisdom
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
well we do have time for questions and
answers from the audience i just want to
let you when i come up to the microphone
you can just speak in your normal tone
because we'll hear you and i'll
be right back before we start though i
want to make a comment brian i remember
last year when you spoke and then this
year
your book has been the recipient of the
2003 um colby award could you tell us a
little bit about that
sure well can i bob can i ask you to
tell
can i have the honor there's a very
distinguished author we have here
tonight
uh bob sorley and he will do a much a
better job and
much more eloquent job of describing
this he is part of the symposium
uh i was just awarded the award from it
so
sure i'd be honored to do that the
military
writers symposium at norwich university
is the venue
in which the colby writers award is
presented
the first year that they had such a
symposium william colby the former
director of central intelligence was
the leading figure taking part by the
time of the next year's
conference he had died and so to honor
him and thank him for what he had done
they named it then the colby military
writer symposium
and each year at norwich university over
a period of about three days
young authors like brian are invited
there
to talk about their books to go to
classes to sign books in the bookstore
and then the peace day resistance is a a
panel session with about six authors and
a moderator
uh and then a banquet at which the the
uh
recipient of the award is uh is given
his award
and that is always given to a first-time
author
although the others who take part uh may
be very well-known authors so
this year in the spring at norwich bran
was
was the recipient of the colby award and
he gave a great talk there tonight is an
expansion i would say
of even more interesting than that
congratulations thank you bob sam
appreciate it let's get to the first
question here
i'd like to ask whether you ran across
any ranking personalities who were
officers at the very heart of racism in
germany members of the reichseger
the sd and the ss i asked that because
i didn't ever run across this i was
field office commander of cic in berlin
right after the war rounding these guys
up and this
this question never really arose good
question sir
you're speaking about the extermination
policies and then you're probably
talking more about the ss
and i have found a few men who were
a part of the ss but they're a small
small minority and no distinguished
personalities
and that the ss was very very methodical
about looking into the ancestry of their
personnel if you're an enlisted
personnel you got to take your ancestry
back to 1800
if you're an officer you've got to take
it back to 1750. there was one notorious
case
of a woman who probably was responsible
for several hundred if not a few
thousand
of people's deaths who was a jew who
served
in the capacity of a catcher a grifer
under the gestapo
her name was stella goldschlag and she
was called the blonde
poison she was very beautiful uh a woman
blonde blue eyed
they had the gessopod even promised her
potential
honorary aryan status after the war she
continued on working for them and
watched what they did to her is
they deported her parents had her
parents write
a couple hundred postcards then killed
the parents
and then had the postcards you know one
postcard go every two or three weeks
then they employed her in the gestapo
office in berlin and said hey if you
work for us
we'll keep your parents alive and you
will remain alive what we want you to do
is go around and find the jews in hiding
and then tell us where they are
so she would go around finding jews and
say hey i'm also looking for a hiding
place can you tell me where to go and
where to hide in your address book
and then she would take it back so this
is a horrible situation
on what was going on with a few of the
people i've identified
earhart's milk the field marshal he
could also be considered a war criminal
he was a half jew and he knew about the
extermination
going on he knew about slave labor going
to auschwitz to be processed
he also knew about the experiments going
on in dachau and he actually sanctioned
them
the high altitude experiments and after
the war he was brought up in the second
nuremberg trials and found guilty
and sentenced to life in prison he was
let out after 10 years and did a lot of
work i think for
bmw and mercedes and and so on so you do
have a small small
percentage but luckily none of the the
higher ups
that you might be thinking about
heidrick there was a lot of
rumors about him heydrich the ss general
there's a lot of rumors that he possibly
had jewish ancestry
possibly even hitler and while this
question comes up quite often i'll go
ahead and answer this especially since
it's jermaine to your question because
if heidrick did have jewish ancestry
he would be one of the people that
you're talking about one thing that we
can be certain about these two people
is that they worry that they had jewish
ancestry according to
dr fritz redlich the former
head of psychiatry at yale university he
wrote a book called hitler the diagnosis
of a destructive prophet
and he goes ver really into depth about
hitler's
tormented soul in many respects about
the fear of possibly having jewish
ancestry
and you know these are the facts about
hitler hitler's grandmother
was 42 years old working in a home
in austria as a maid when she suddenly
becomes pregnant
and when hitler was rising uh in the 20s
and in the 30s there was a lot of rumors
rising in the political arena
there's a lot of rumors about his
potential jewish background because his
father
was born a shuckle grouper wasn't born
hitler his father later on took the
adopted name hitler when he was in his
40s and it's
interesting to think that had his father
not done it if hitler could have
actually risen to power with heil sheker
grouper it just doesn't doesn't
it just doesn't sound right but there
was a lot of rumors going around back
then
of hither having jewish background huns
frank his lawyer
claimed in the nuremberg trials after
the war that hitler with all these
rumors flying around
ordered him in late 20s early 30s to go
down to
austria and inspect this and hunts frank
claimed that he found
documents that the grand grandmother had
been working in a jewish
home in grotz frank and roger
frankenberger we've never been able to
find this family by the way
uh but according to his testimony that
he the
grandmother was working in this home
when she suddenly becomes pregnant
and then he found correspondence between
the jewish family and hither's
grandmother
and for 13 years hitler was
given child support interesting law in
the books back then in
austria was that if you had a child at a
wedlock and they knew who you were you
had to support the kid for 13 years
and you're seeing coincidence also when
the nuremberg laws came out
hitler had it ordered that no aryan
woman
under the age of 45 could work in a
jewish home for fear that she would be
impregnated
coincidence you know also he had
supposedly
a lot of documents about his family
destroyed uh and also even a cemetery i
destroyed
uh in dollarsheim so hitler was
definitely
scared about something he had many
reason to be scared about
several things in his family especially
back in that generation you know his
father was born out of wedlock
his father was an alcoholic his father
beat his mother and beat the kids even
beat the dog
uh there was a history of incest in the
family
and there was a history of insanity
surprise surprise
uh and uh these type of things he had a
lot of demons he was trying to get rid
of and red lick really focuses on his
book
about the possibility of jewish ancestry
heydrich is also the same story he had a
lot of people in the 20s and 30s
throwing
rumors at adam hey you have jewish
ancestry uh the soos in your family was
actually jewish and so on and bruno
heydrich
you know i i interviewed somebody who
actually had a mother who took piano
lessons under bunoh hydrate bruno
heydrich was the father of
heydrich and he was a musician and music
teacher in hala and everybody thought he
was a jew in town
so when hajduk was rising up heidrik
didn't look anything like his father his
father was short
dark swarthy and so a lot of people said
yeah he's a jew he has to be look at him
his son was very tall blonde and
blue-eyed and so he never got it for his
phenotypical
trace although he had a very high voice
and in the navy they actually called him
the blonde moses
and they're saying enough and so he took
people to court several times for
slander for calling you know him of
jewish uh
you know dissent and so on and he
definitely worried about it but those
are the
you know only two cases where you're
talking about the center of
extermination policies
where you might have heard yeah there
were some of those people of jewish sent
like heydrich but there's no documents
to prove it all right we have a question
over here
could you comment about the motives of
the jewish soldiers
were they in support of the german ames
or the nazi ames
or were they just doing this to survive
and for their family survival very good
question sir
you know we have to realize that most of
these men were drafted
they had to serve they didn't have a
choice also
one thing we have to realize and this is
the sad tragedy of german jewry
is that they came from very proud
traditions of military service
let's not forget that in world war one
one hundred thousand german jews served
in the german military
twelve thousand of them died in combat
more jews died in the german
military in world war one than all jews
and israeli conflicts from 1948 to 1982.
the austrian-hungarian empire is even a
more dramatic example
three hundred thousand jews served in
the uh empire's military in world one
twenty five thousand died in combat more
jews died in the austrian military more
one than all jews and all israeli
conflicts to date
so these men came from very strong
military traditions their fathers and
grandfathers
uncles cousins had all been drafted so
when they were drafted
yes there was a lot of confusion
at times but they didn't think it is as
absurd as we do today
they were serving their country also
many of them in the 30s thought
hitler will be just like one of the
other weinmar republic parties
rise up do a few things and then be
kicked out
they didn't think he was going to be
there for 12 years and they definitely
didn't think that they would start
being exterminated especially when they
were serving now getting back getting to
another angle
of your question many of these men what
gave their service meaning once they
were there were saying hey they're not
going to touch a grandmother
they're not going to touch a mother of a
soldier especially if i had the iron
cross
so many of them were doing more in
combat to help protect their families
and also protect themselves so it was to
one extent
uh to be part of the crowd you know to
do every
do uh what everybody else in society was
doing and also
survive now the full jews a lot of times
that was strictly survival technique
but when you get to the half jews and
quarter jews
you're dealing with choiceless choice to
lose a lawrence longers
for a wonderful as a writer of his uh
holocaust
testimonies you're dealing with a lot of
choices choice
with these men and had they gone to the
authority and said hey i don't want to
serve i feel jewish
you're persecuting my family not only do
they put themselves in jeopardy but they
put their whole family in jeopardy
and in countless cases these men's
service did
actually postpone and even in some cases
actually prevent
the deportation and death of loved ones
gestapo agents come to the
house to pick up grandma and they see a
picture of of all the grandsons in
military uniform
and they go away confused and sometimes
guys come home from the front they hear
about granddad being deported or mom
being deported they go to the
deportation station in full dress
military uniform
the guy's like hey we can't deport a
mother of a soldier that happened
countless times which i was not
expecting to find
but the testimonies and the documents
prove it brian we have a question over
here
yes matt i have several questions if i
may well first one
did hitler know about the captain of the
bismarck
having jewish blood and henrisi isn't
henry
was wife was jewish or something they're
well informed
uh your first question the the the
um fleet commander uh that the bismarck
was part of
was lucian's a lot of people think uh
that commander captain lucian's was of
jewish descent
i have not found any documents on
luchan's background the reason why
people think he was a jewish descent was
because of his wife
a born back and caller who was a half
jew and his sons were
naval officers and also aryanized also
his brother-in-law
was admiral bacchancolor who was
aryanized who was a half-jew
so he got a lot thrown on him so to
speak because of who he had married
just like general carl august von
gablins
who also was one of the key people in
building up the luffaffa
a lot of people thought that he was of
jewish descent and there possibly might
be
i've taken his ancestry back five
generations and i can't find anything
yet
because in the nazi documents there's a
lot of stuff that is written that he was
of jewish descent
and he was having a lot of problems uh
what's interesting is that his wife
was of jewish descent and he got a lot
of flack so to speak
because of that heinrichy is another
example you're well informed
heinrichy was a four-star general
okay
thank you sir yeah yes
heinrich he was uh he was in charge of
the defense of berlin at the end of the
war it was a brilliant defensive
strategist
and he had a half jewish wife and she
and their children had to submit these
lengthy
lengthy uh applications of one of the
son who later became a captain in the
army he had to submit 10 photographs
before hitler decided to arionize the
family
and and he the son served the entire war
and heinrich he served
with little difficulty although hitler
had
some problems with him because he spoke
his mind and got into hitler's face
quite a bit
and there are some third fourth hand
stories i've heard of hitler going i
should have never arionized his wife
but i couldn't substantiate those claims
so i didn't bring it into my book
although it was a wonderful story
two others if i met do you know uh
professor mikhail's
from clan cl um clemson university
uh professor hussain mikhail mchale he
wrote a
hitler shadow war
and he simply says hitler was just what
you said that hitler was more interested
in
in exterminating the jews and even
winning the war in russia or even
winning the war period
so i think i thought it was excellent
because it was the first time
that i always suspected that but
when i picked up this book i think it
recently came out
he's from clemson university professor
and he's not jewish
wrote this thing and i think it's good
the other i would agree with him
i would agree with him totally okay um
just another one if i may
about europa europa mrs holland
uh who wrote who directed it or produced
it and they were expecting that to win
to win the foreign film award in khan
and they didn't do you know why you guys
excuse me from my ignorance sir i do not
know
oh okay well we'll end on one final note
um
i saw you in the research room today and
you were doing research at the national
archives
what were you doing and what's coming up
next for you
um i i've been very blessed i just
signed a two book contract with yale
university
press and the book that i've been
working on here the national archives
has been great
with helping me find these documents is
as i was doing my research i came across
this crazy story
about an ultra ultra orthodox rabbi
being rescued by half jewish abdar
officers
half jewish secret service military
officers
as i look more and more into it and have
been mentioned here and there in a few
books and
one book winfrey meyer wrote in his book
on janine zeman
about 10 pages on it and it was a
fascinating story and he was the most a
thorough author that i
found that had explored this but there
was still a lot
still a lot left to be known and so as i
started looking more and more into this
i realized that
our government actually was responsible
for the rescue of this guy what happened
was the lubavitchers
this this rabbi was a the the head of
the lobolature movement
his name was isak schneerson and the
lobovichus is a hasidic group
uh and they are ultra ultra orthodox
beard side locks you know black uh
suits you know the fur hats and very
very pious that's what hasidic means in
hebrew
pious and at the time it's very
difficult to ascertain exactly how many
followers he had
but according to the documents here in
this archive the
the leaders here in america were giving
that there were 160 000 followers in
america
and they're very passionate and they're
very very loyal
to this man they believe that he is the
moshi rabbenu the the moses of
his generation he's also the potential
messiah if the messiah is going to come
it will be through him and also he's
almost he has almost like a direct link
to the divine in many respects i mean he
is very holy
i mean it would you know for christians
today if you tell them
you know jesus made a lot of mistakes
and he might not be the son of god
you know how a lot of christians would
react to that they would react the same
way about the rebbe if you said anything
like that derogatory about their
uh reppie so when the rebbe was in
warsaw in 1939 when germany invaded
these guys in america 160 000 went crazy
and they started writing the government
help us save this rebbe very
distinguished man he had traveled
here in 1929 met president hoover met
brandeis
met a few senators senators wagner and
cohen and so on so he was fairly well
connected in the government as well
so this made it all the way up to
cordell hall and must have gotten to
roosevelt as well
and they decided to take this very
seriously they had election coming up in
1940
a lot of people are interested in this
case a lot of politicians are knocking
on their doors james farley and so on
let's take it seriously so they got in
touch with robert pell in the state
department the foreign affairs office
and pal had been at the avian conference
in 1938
when they were talking about refugees
there and they met
some germans one of them being guring
secretary of state
uh of the four-year plan and although
the refugee
crisis there was not solved volta told
pell that if there is ever a jew in
germany that you want to rescue
just get in touch with me and i'll take
care of it well in 1939
when he hull and uh a few others in the
government got in touch with pell he
said
i'll get in touch with will todd he'll
help us out got in touch with volton
volta said yes i'll do it and he got in
touch with canaris
the head of the secret service of the uh
german military the abvare
and canara said okay i'll take care of
it and that's where i come into play
he went to ernst bloch and said who's
half jew and said hey i got a mission
for you
i want you to take some other guys who
are michelin up to warsaw
find the rebbe and rescue him and so
block does what he said
told he later on rescued some other
people and got him to switzerland so
this was a project that they were doing
so
but if you can just imagine the
situation these men are going up to
warsaw
full dra you know full military uniform
and they're going around to ultra
hasidic jews going hey
we've been ordered to come up here and
find your rebbe and help rescue him can
you tell us where he is
yeah you know these city jews are like
yeah oh that's great and i want to join
the ss
yeah where do i sign yeah so there's a
lot of
you know the rebbe going to different
houses trying to escape these guys are
there to kill him you know
a lot of intrigue going on then they
finally convinced the rebbe through
telegrams coming from the the
americas on to riga that there is this
officer he's there to help you trust him
so they do trust him now block is faced
with going through ss checkpoints
with these ultra ultra orthodox jews you
know his mother is with him the rebbe's
mother is with him his wife
his grandson his son-in-law his daughter
i mean you got a whole flock of them
right there and so he'll get out into
the ss and like you know these jewish
pigs were taking them
to berlin we're going to shoot them
after we interrogate them they're under
diplomat i'm under diplomatic orders to
take them
then it gets back into their car and
according to the documents he must have
told them eventually sometime anybody
says hey don't worry
i'm half jewish i'm here to help you
yeah what's going on here
you know it doesn't make sense finally
he gets them to berlin
from berlin since the most of the jews
that were in this party were latvian
citizens
they get them on to uh riga
from riga they get them in stockholm
from stockholm there's a comedy of eras
of
you know everything they have to go
through and then finally they get into
the ocean you boat infested waters and
they make it to america
and now we have the head of lubovic in
brooklyn new york
and the largest hasidic sect uh in the
world so
that's the next book that i'm working on
well
if brian mark rigg can come here to the
national archives so can you we've got
facilities all around the country come
here come to our website archives.gov
first of all c-span thank you very much
for coming for book tv thank you all
very much for coming and ladies and
gentlemen brian mark rigg
brian mark rigg is author of hitler's
jewish soldiers
it's published by university press of
kansas
on the web at kansaspress.ku.edu